حكيم على زوجها من قبل بحيازه النقد
الاجنبي واليوم هي المتهمه بتهمه الثراء
الحرام والمشبوه داخل محكمه جرائم الفساد
ومخالفات المال العام بالخرطوم وبعد ثلاث
سنوات من المداولات على وداد بابكر زوجه
الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير قضت المحكمه
بمصادره عقارات واراض زراعيه ومشغوله
ذهبيه ورغم ضخامه الغرامه التي تقدر ب 100
مليون جنيه لصالح حكومه السودان الا ان
العقوبه مخففه بنظره قانوني
لم تتم محاكمتها بموجب قانون ازاله تمكين
او قانون يعني التغيير الاجتماعي الحصري
يعني بموجب مقتضياته وقوانينه وانما
بقانون لانقاذ ذات نفسه كثير من
القانونيين السودانيين يعتقدوا ان هذا
الحكم جاء يعني مخففا لم ياتي هذا الحكم
مشدده الظرف الشده المفترضه والمتوقع
على الجانب الاخر يرى المدافعون عن وداد
بابكر ان المحكمه شابتها مخالفات وانهم
ماضون في استئناف القرار الان القرار من
المحكمه اليوم صادر كل ممتلكات ابناء على
الرغم منه ابناء برضو مواجهه اتهام وفصل
البلاغ في مواجهتهم او فصول الالتهاب في
مواجهات الممارسه المحليه من يقدم
مواطنون ان الاجراء هو الطريق الصحيح
لاسترداد اموال الدوله المنهوبه عبر
القضاء لارسال العداله
دائما لانه صورتنا
صوره امنيه على ثلاثه اجزاء
حريه سلام عداله
في اموال مهربه
تضعوا المواطن السوداني مراقبه
في تحقيق العداله وخوفي من ضياعي حقه لين
يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم